Amazon has become the world's first
company to lose one trillion dollars
worth of market value dropping from 1.88
trillion down to 879 billion in fact
Amazon's trailing 12-month profit has
plunged from over 30 billion down to
even negative numbers and all of this
has unfolded within just two years of
Jeff Bezos retiring from his position as
CEO this has led to many investors
feeling that it was a Bezos that was the
secret sauce to Amazon's success
sparking rumors that Bezos will return
to the helm to turn around the company
one investor named Michael batnick has
even gone as far as predicting that
Bezos will return by the end of 2023
this might sound unprecedented but
that's not actually the case in fact
it's pretty common versus Yost return if
things aren't going great so the idea of
Bezos returning is not that far-fetched
and considering the current position of
Amazon it's well warranted too